first diagnosis was pretty bad
you know they ever seen it I could
probably die within a couple of years
the mine is one of the most aggressive
forms of non-hodgkin lymphoma that they
pretty much ever seen so a company like
that has money they can fight a long
time like I said this fight might go
past my life lee johnson sued Monsanto
and won the jury awarded him two hundred
and eighty nine million dollars in
August of 2018 after concluding his
cancer was linked to exposure to Roundup
Monsanto's controversial toxic weed
killer and that's when I had the shower
of Ranger Pro all over me he went down
in my protective gear went down in my
suit everywhere Johnson was working as a
groundskeeper at a few different schools
for about four years and using a
concentrated version of roundup called
Ranger Pro while most passed cases
against the chemical giant haven't gone
anywhere Johnson's has and could open
the door for thousands of others who say
they're sick because of Monsanto I was
even told you know Lee you know want to
try to go lucky and stacked up it
and I had no choice cuz I had no job I
was sick so I had to do what I needed to
do
[Music]
it goes through the plant to kill it
tops and rhizomes the more complete
control of roundup lasts longer than one
year but is it worth it Monsanto's
flagship product roundup has been the
center of a heated debate for years it's
the most widely used weed killer in the
world 19 billion pounds of it have
already been used since its release in
the 70s it's on the food we eat it's
sprayed on playgrounds at dog parks it's
everywhere its key ingredient glyphosate
was classified as a probable carcinogen
by the World Health Organization in 2015
since then Monsanto now owned by Bayer
and its advocates have made it a mission
to convince people in the government
that their product is safe you can drink
a whole quart of it and it won't hurt
you if you want to drink them we have
some here I'd be happy to actually yeah
not not really but not really I know it
wouldn't hurt not stupid the use of
roundup skyrocketed in the mid-90s when
Monsanto created genetically modified
crops that can resist the chemical this
led to farming practices like spraying
roundup across whole fields and as a
result on the food that people named
glyphosate isn't regulated by the USDA
or the EPA the FDA only recently started
testing foods for it after prompting
from consumer groups and the Government
Accountability Office and so once they
gave you the diagnosis what was your
reaction that was the worst you know to
hear that that was the worst they didn't
want to see that you know the type of
cancer that they saw
in the test so they did another test and
this time my wife went they did that
test was pretty back she broke down and
started crying and all that then they
found out you know that I had cancer did
I not Hodgins lymphoma
I have some painful lesions right now I
have some stuff going on but I've been
doing this for so long and I'm starting
to get used to the pain
what were your kids reactions when you
first told them so breaking the newest
of them is really hard because you don't
really as soon as you say cancers people
just count you out they picture you laid
out to come they see me every day so
they see what I go through so they were
told but then they see it they've seen a
way bottom where I've been
we're headed to Venetian California the
place where I used to work yeah that's
when I got a super big exposure because
the host bro come on oh my equipment and
that's when I had the shower of Ranger
Pro all over me and went down in my
protective gear went down in my suit
everywhere they don't use roundup in the
whole town anymore they don't use it at
all they stop using the formula at all I
mean but I don't know whatever chemicals
they use but they definitely stop using
that yes yes in this town and in another
town about an hour from here called
Nevada Nevada also quit using the
formulation life estate is banned by
cities and counties across the country
France Germany and a handful of other
countries have also announced plans to
phase it out or restrict it so I'm glad
to say we made it past the threshold of
where we can actually get more testing
in the conversations are obviously
brewing about what's going on with our
food when our soil and everything so
it's a big deal it's way bigger than me
you know so it was a part of the
situation now Johnson hopes his case
will bring awareness to the dangers of
using roundup near schools but what
we're pushing for is there's a
glyphosate free campuses that's my push
my goal is to have
pesticide-free campuses for all schools
people that are talking about this and
the the wave of attention is guidance
like people are like tentacles of me I
don't really have to say much or do much
because there's so many people that have
doing it for me and they're doing it now
and I'm probably doing it after me you
know the the keep rounds and keep farms
and keep food safe a few months after
the ruling the judge overturned at the
jury's award reducing it to 78 million
Johnson agreed to the new amount but
still hasn't received any money yet to
help pay for his cancer treatments I was
almost only ghost money I know I don't
like the attention at the same time it's
a lot of time and it was hard going
there and to focus on trying to do that
again even though it's worth a quarter
billion dollars it's not really worth
because it was never about the money for
me so I think that the courts have done
their fair justice so right now you know
after me accepting the offer that was
given it's up to the other side to
decide whether or not we go back to
court we've already said publicly over
and over to think on appeal so we're
expecting a year before - worth of
Appeals maybe more that's what I'm
saying this thing could outdo me
Monsanto representatives declined to sit
down for an interview with us but said
they would be appealing there are
currently over 8,000 outstanding
lawsuits against Monsanto Lee's case
could set a legal precedent that could
affect the outcome of others who wish to
hold the company accountable I hope that
is an inspiration to people that would
think that you know if they had somebody
or a company or something that wronged
them if you go up against something
bigger than you you they can get crushed
or you can win so I would say to use my
story as an example did you actually
could win
[Music]